[Music]
[Music]
hmm welcome to the new project camp
update so in the previous video you
could see us working on a very sketchy
room with a wall that is about to fall
still standing and but in today's video
we're actually gonna reinforce it we
bought some boots the van is completely
overloaded very solid strong wood and
we're gonna make a frame inside that
should
keep everything together so we got one
super solid ruin in the end
let's see
so the roof rack is a little bit bended
here which is not a problem there's only
a solar panel underneath to
catch the wood
[Music]
coming
[Music]
so before we start building let me show
you the current status of this beautiful
orange creature
so last time we rebuilt the outer wall
and at this point is very fragile still
standing but very weak
and we notice nothing inside this rune
is straight well let me show you
[Music]
so here you can see a beam against the
wall it's pretty straight
and then it just goes
very
[Music]
curved here's the line of the wall
and here's the end
so making a frame in the house is going
to be quite a challenge because really
nothing is 90 degrees
and the whole walls are bended so here
you can see for instance
an angle
i just put my finger in here even though
it's 90 degree here and this wall itself
is also completely curved and the width
here is more than the width there
so
and the height is higher there than here
so on all sides the whole angles are
very hard very hard to make 3d model out
of it
so i think a lot of it's going to be
just measuring putting it up putting it
down measuring it again cutting it
measuring cutting measure cutting
until we can make it fit
custom-made
we tried to make a 3d model out of this
ruin in sketchup small side note we
actually did a vote in discord to see
which 3d software would be best winners
were blenders ketchup and 360 fusion so
we'll be using those to document our
things anyway 3d model is useful but
hard to match with reality
so it will be an ongoing effort of
drawing measuring fitting back to
drawing measuring and fitting
so yeah let's get started first thing
prepare the floor
[Music]
so before we're going to install the
wooden beams we need to level the floor
a bit because there's a lot of stuff and
uneven things on here
and to make sure it's flat and also
while we're at it we're going to try to
make a little bit of a gutter here
because in the winter we're probably
going to have condensation coming from
this outer wall
and if we're going to heat at the inside
and it's going to drip down and if we
don't do anything it would
fade
in here
we're going to try to curve a little bit
of a channel um
in the floor because then the water is
distributed and the upside of the ruin
that is not completely leveled is that
it would all flow to that corner
so just a little channel make sure all
the condensation goes out as well
hammer time
[Music]
all right so the floor is ready now it's
time to build so next we're going to
make a wooden frame inside to create the
load of the roof and holds everything
together
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
time
[Music]
so before we're gonna put up the beam in
the ruin we're gonna sand them and oil
them to make sure that they last long
purpose to live in the house so what's
the last part
i don't know it's like you want to live
in the house so you got to make sure
that it stays
because you don't want to get some
mildew in your beams
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we have the wood oiled and
the floor is cleaned so now it's time
for assembly so we're going to put this
frame up on the bottom and then we're
going to lift it up and then we will
continue to build
out the frame and keep measuring all the
weird angles
and we got colleen for some extra power
[Applause]
[Music]
does this feel doable
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so it's currently uh middle of the day
but it's super hot
so we just put up the three beams and we
need to continue so we're gonna try
a thing where we're gonna wake up at six
work in the morning and then the
afternoon we take it
chill
because it's hot nap
waterfall
how old is it
it's
33 now but uh i think in four days it's
gonna be 41 so
no can do no gain do construction
i can do construction
[Music]
[Music]
you ready
okay
you like the mornings
why are you filming now you're killing
me
it's very nice actually starting early
still fresh and cool there's a fork
hanging in the valley and slowly the sun
is rising and it's getting warmer so now
we can continue to build up the frame
so clean is now finishing up oiling the
last beams now we're going to build that
side of the ruin
which is actually going to be way more
difficult this was sort of the straight
part but here's a big curve in
there it's lower on that side on that
side that corner is not 90 degree but
less
so
this is going to be a more challenging
part
we're experienced now right
yes so so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're now going to put on our highest
point beam
we're full of energy
beams are super light
should be easy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right so we have a challenge here
all the beams are now on the roof which
is cool except for the last one we're
adopting
and mainly all the beans are not
perpendicular to each other except for
the last one because the last one
follows the
wall but let me show you
so this beam is now perfectly over the
wall but yeah not perpendicular to these
ones anymore
which makes it looks a bit weird and as
you can see on the outside this beam is
sticking out a lot like a meter more
than that and the main reason is because
this wall is just not uh under the right
angle it's not 90 degrees it should be
more like this
but that's not the case so the question
now is whether we should change that
beam the same as the other ones
perpendicular or we keep putting it
under an angle so it's above the wall
and it's easier to close everything so
that's the question
colleen here made a nice
pro and con list
so this the crooked one like it already
is that means less work for everything
except for the insulation
okay
and the other one if we put everything
straight it's
less work for everything except for the
wall construction
and the fact that we need to move it
again so in the end we must really think
whether it's more trouble for us to work
on the insulation if it's crooked or to
work on the wall if it's straight
that's the question
i think
it's harder to put them straight but
it's maybe better
realistically we don't really know
i think so we're gonna have a screw
decide
if it falls in that direction we go
perpendicular if it falls in that
direction we go for the angle
is that okay for you
shoot
like now
yeah think it's more towards me
it looks like really in the middle
okay
what do we say
it goes to you
so to me would be the
crooked one angled right after we solved
that crucial issue with this extreme
professional screw method we just let
the beam how it was not perpendicular
add to the other beams but fitting above
the wall not sure if this will make
sense in the long term or would get us
more in trouble but let's see
anyway meanwhile the heatwave arrived in
project camp and things started to
become a bit weird
how's it going
good i was thinking about sending
because we're standing near sand so
sending could be any activity that you
do near sand
sand
standing
yeah not sure what was going on but at
some point colleen started talking weird
stuff like this so we figured maybe
we're overheating i mean there was a
heat wave going on so yeah maybe time
for a break
so
since you might have realized it's
summer here in portugal
usually summer is nice because it's warm
and sunny and you can eat ice cream
but here in portugal it can get a bit
intense and if i'm saying intense i mean
more insane
this week is by far the hottest we had
here in camp
at 9 in the morning it's already 30
degrees celsius plus
until afternoon it climbs then easily
till 44. as you might imagine activities
like cooking laptop work video making or
just existing become more and more an
act of survival in these temperatures
you need to get creative if you don't
want to get cooked like a lobster but
even then it's more suffering than
anything else
so we decided to have a break and take a
ride to rio dal
a beautiful river located close to
project camp with big boulders and nice
water to cool ourselves down and have a
lunch
later when it's a bit less hot we're
gonna continue with construction work
okay guys where are we right now the
river down
why are we here
to cool down in the nice water
sounds good
and eat lunch
keep telling you the one thing
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right so it's now end of the day
we're refreshed
and now we can do some cement work also
because the heat is gone
and what we want to do now is since we
built the frame to build back up the
wall here and this is really going to
connect a straight wooden frame with a
very wobbly brick wall but it should
make everything super tight and straight
not straight just tight
and we also added these metal rods here
on each corner of the beam with a plug
on the outside so it would build back
the wall these would be cemented in and
then later we can tighten them really to
make sure it's one solid strong piece so
ideally after this
it should feel really good
we also put in a few metal rods here
that once we build up the wall it
doesn't slide off and stays in place
[Music]
if
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so the wall here is now done
and that one partially as well still
a lot of other walls to go it's going to
be an ongoing process takes quite long
especially with the heat as well
and but we'll continue to work on it
so yeah make sure to subscribe if you
already want to see the next video
or support on patreon actually you can
already see the next video one week
ahead
[Music]
anyway we'll just continue working share
the updates here thank you for watching
see you next time
[Music]
can you see that i'm so red
on the camera
maybe why are you red because it's very
hot
today's the hottest day of the world
we have a yellow beam a green background
and a red color
yes
it's jamaica moment
in the construction industry they call
me the lobster
sometimes i think you're not aware that
this could be broadcasted to hundred
thousands of people the things you say
but it's only people in the state
your mom might be watching
my mom is probably watching because i
send her the link